(rhythmic music)
(elevator pings)
- Here it is, fourth floor.
- Oh, thanks.
- Once again, Mr.
O'Brien, it is so exciting
to have you here in San Diego.
I'm a big fan of
entertainment of all kinds.
This is kinda the biggest
celebrity we've had here
since I think Comic-Con
2007, Michael Chiklis.
He's great.
- He's very good.
- You know, some people like the Hulk,
but I'm a Thing man myself.
- Oh, okay.
- And I do think you have to choose.
You hear some people say, "I
like the Hulk and the Thing."
Take a position, you know.
- [Conan] Yeah.
- Hey, while you're here,
you gotta go to the naval base.
You gotta do that, promise
me you're gonna do that.
- I don't know if we'll have time.
- And SeaWorld, you gotta go to SeaWorld.
(audience laughs)
You probably heard they
got rid of the whales.
- Yeah, I did hear that.
(audience laughs)
- It's so sad because
what are those whales
gonna do now, you know?
There's not a lot of
opportunities for whales.
(audience laughs)
That was
a good job for a whale.
Hey, you know where else you
can go though, is Legoland.
Have you been to Legoland?
- [Conan] Uh, no, I've never been there.
- [Bellhop] Okay, well,
here is the problem.
You literally cannot get
in there if you're an adult
just going alone without a kid.
They won't let you in.
(audience laughs)
Isn't that crazy?
You're thrown into a position
to have to find a kid
so you can get in, and
I can find you a kid.
Like, if you need a kid
to get into Legoland,
- No, I don't want a kid
(audience laughs)
- I have a lead on two different kids.
One of them is getting a little old but...
- Okay.
I'd rather not know about it.
- He looks young.
(audience laughs)
And here is your room.
- This is it?
- This is it.
- We got off the elevator right there.
(audience laughs)
- That's right.
You're gonna be right by the elevator.
- So why did we go all the way?
- Oh, the cart isn't great
with left-hand turns.
I just preferred to do a right.
(audience laughs)
A little bit of circle.
- I, I'm really tired.
I'd just love to get inside.
- You must be tired, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Do you have a key?
(audience laughs)
- Yeah.
- A lot of the bellhops
have keys that they can get
into all the rooms, but they
don't give me one anymore.
I had one.
- What did you do?
- It's not something I'm super proud of.
(audience laughs)
- Um, your name again is, is?
- [Bellhop] It's Frederick.
- Frederick.
- Hey listen, if you need anything,
just pick up your phone,
dial nine and then star.
- Mm-hmm.
- And then seven, seven, and then hang up
and then pick it up again
and then nine again.
(audience laughs)
And then three or four six's,
and then wait like a minute
and I should pick up,
unless I'm on my break or
unless that doesn't work.
It might not work.
- I'm just gonna go in.
- [Frederick] Uh, yeah, all right, yeah.
Have a good night's sleep.
You're gonna like this room.
- Terrific, thank you so
much, and we'll see you later.
- Yeah, you want me to
come in and help you
turn on your fireplace or anything?
- No, I got it myself.
- Are you sure?
- Thank you.
- [Frederick] Have a good night's sleep!
- We're good.
(exhales)
(slow dramatic music)
(fire blazing)
(audience laughs)
(audience laughs and applauds)
(door knocking)
(audience laughs)
- Hi, sorry to bug you, but I thought
you might like some ice.
- Uh, I think I'm good, thank you.
- Hey, this really does a
great job keeping things cold.
- That's what ice is kind of famous for,
but I think I don't need ice.
- Okay, sorry to bother you.
(slow dramatic music)
(audience laughs)
(door knocking)
Toblerone!
- I'm, I'm really not a
Toblerone guy, but thank you.
- Are you sure?
This is from my own private stash.
- [Conan] I know but thank you.
Just thanks very much.
(slow dramatic music)
(door knocking)
Son of a bitch!
(audience laughs)
- You know what this is.
Do you need it?
- (sighs) I, no.
I'm just gonna go number one, okay, so...
- Just number one all night long?
Hey, Mr. O'Brien.
- Look,
(audience laughs)
I do these shows.
I'm tired and I need to sleep.
(door shuts)
(audience laughs)
- Oops.
- You're sure I have to go all the way
to the lobby for a new key?
- Yeah, that's policy.
(Conan groans)
You have an ID, right?
- No, I don't have ID.
- Ah, that's all right.
Everybody knows that face.
(audience laughs)